JUDY WOODRUFF: Now the story
of a young man teaching
math to the world.
NewsHour correspondent
Spencer Michels reports.
SALMAN KHAN: So this is a
quadratic equation essentially.
We're trying to find the 0s of--
SPENCER MICHELS: This
disembodied voice
is heard every day
by tens of thousands
of students struggling
with math both in the US
and around the world.
SALMAN KHAN: So what is
x squared plus 4x plus 4?
Well, it's x plus
2 times x plus 2.
SPENCER MICHELS: 33-year-old
Salman Khan recently
quit his job as a
hedge fund analyst
to devote himself to
an unpaid job teaching
math on the internet.
SALMAN KHAN: Welcome to the
presentation on basic addition.
These are cancers
or cancer cells.
The investors in the
mortgage-backed securities--
SPENCER MICHELS: He has
posted 1,200 lessons
on YouTube, which appear on
an electronic blackboard,
and range in subject from basic
addition and advanced calculus,
to science and finance.
And they are free.
SALMAN KHAN: Introduction
to Trigonometry,
this is where I teach people
about the trig functions.
This is one of the
more popular videos.
This has 179,000 views.
And this is just what sine,
cosine, and tangent are,
SPENCER MICHELS: Khan lives
in California's Silicon Valley
with his wife, a rheumatologist
in training at Stanford,
and their new baby.
He got the idea for Khan
Academy four years ago
when he taught a
young cousin how
to convert kilograms to grams.
Many American students
have trouble with math,
and studies show they lag behind
their counterparts in Asia
and Europe in both
math and science.
With Khan's help, his
cousin got good at math,
and he eventually
had a new career
tapping into anxieties
around the world.
Now he records his lessons
from a converted closet
in the back of his bedroom.
He never goes on camera.
SALMAN KHAN: It kind of feels
like the voice in their head.
You're looking at
it, it kind of feels
like someone's over your
shoulder talking in your year
as opposed to someone
at a blackboard that's
distant from you. [COUGH]
Sorry for starting
the presentation with a cough.
But now I want to continue
with the 45-45-90 triangles.
SPENCER MICHELS: Although
he is not the first person
to teach on the internet,
his simple operation
has attracted more eyeballs
than most university sites.
And his fame has spread.
The all-girl Castilleja
School in Palo Alto
invited Khan to speak,
and he immediately
connected to the student body.
SALMAN KHAN: You tell
me that you really
don't know how, dividing
decimals is still
kind of this little gray
area, and if dividing decimals
actually is, you're not alone.
Dividing decimals is
kind of the one thing
that no one wants to admit that
they kind of forgot how to do.
SPENCER MICHELS: He exuded
pride in his expanding
online audience.
SALMAN KHAN: More and more
people kept watching it,
and now it's reaching
actually on the order
of 100,000 students now a month
and 40,000 video views a day.
SPENCER MICHELS:
It was the concept
of short, repeatable
lessons that
attracted high
school senior Bridget
Meany who admitted she'd had
trouble with seventh grade
algebra.
BRIDGET MEANY: I think
the teachers are good,
but they can't go at a pace
that's perfect for everyone.
But I like the concept of
knowing something in class,
but then going back and
pressing pause or rewind,
and actually getting a
deeper understanding of it.
SPENCER MICHELS: Shy students
who don't ask questions
in class may benefit the
most from Khan's videos,
says Kimberly Knapp, who
teaches math at Castilleja.
But his lessons aren't a
substitute for the classroom,
KIMBERLY KNAPP: I don't
think that there's
a perfect replacement
for the work that we do
and just the kind
of conversations
that students and teachers
engage in together.
SPENCER MICHELS: But Khan
thinks maybe lecture halls
and classrooms have
their limitations.
Originally he kept
his lessons short
because of YouTube restrictions.
Now he thinks short is better.
SALMAN KHAN: I've gotten
researchers telling me
that you don't realize.
10 minutes, we've
done studies, is
how long someone can have a
high level of concentration,
and anything beyond that,
you kind of lose it.
And I think we've all had that
experience sitting in college
where you can be with the
professor for about 10,
15 minutes.
And then you kind of lose it.
SPENCER MICHELS: A lot of math
students apparently agree.
I talked via the internet
with Cody Woodward
in Anchorage, Alaska who uses
Khan's lessons at college.
CODY WOODWARD: It has
helped me immensely
in the grades for
my math classes,
and I've also learned a lot.
SPENCER MICHELS:
Internet instruction,
be it the Khan Academy or
taped university lectures,
could revolutionize education
in remote, Third World locations
where access to
high-quality instruction
is frequently unavailable.
That's the hope of Neil
Radia, a young software
programmer at Cisco Systems.
He and fellow volunteers
at World Possible,
working on their vacations,
are bringing online teaching
to Africa and
India for starters.
When Radia and Megha Jain
first traveled to Ethiopia,
they found thousands
of brand new computers
sitting idle because
they couldn't connect
to the internet, and
therefore couldn't
get online instruction.
NEIL RADIA: The
great thing to do
would to be putting a
lot of these resources
on a single local server that
we could bring to the colleges,
to the universities,
to community centers.
We came across the Khan Academy.
And we emailed him and asked
him if we could reproduce
some of his material
on our servers,
and he was very
willing to help us out.
MEGHA JAIN: You'd be surprised
how fast these kids learn
and take these things up.
So it isn't strange to them.
They've heard of this, and
they are excited to use it.
SPENCER MICHELS: For
Khan, teaching math
and science and finance
is just the beginning.
He's ready to expand
his YouTube site
to include whatever
strikes his fancy
SALMAN KHAN: I want
to do everything.
I want to do history.
I want to do grammar.
I want to do literally
every subject.
SPENCER MICHELS: So far,
except for a little advertising
revenue, he is donating
his time and equipment.
It's a one-man
operation, but it's
gotten so big he expects
to start soliciting
outside support to keep
his academy growing.